today is Thursday februari 25th I'm Mary
and you're watching gamespot news for
the rich first up let's all give a round
of applause to Victor kiss Lee who made
his first billion the video game
industry has a new billionaire in its
ranks bloomberg reports today that
Victor kiss Lee founder and CEO of
cyprus-based World of Tanks developer
wargaming has a net worth of 1 billion
kiss Lee declined to confirm this number
but in standard rich person fashion he
told the publication that he lives a
very modest lifestyle he's not one to
put a number on his fortune good job
Victor hide your riches money is the
topic that I purposely try to avoid the
company itself is reportedly valued at
1.5 billion dollars kiss Li controls
sixty-four percent of the business
directly and also has his father's 25.5
percent stake according to Bloomberg
wargaming has a network of 150 million
users across the globe the studio is
best known for its free-to-play game
World of Tanks which makes a butt ton of
cash through optional add in content for
poor people the Bloomberg profile on
kiss Lee is a good read if you're a
subscriber to that type of thing packed
with interesting insight into his
luxurious life and various investments I
I really think that money doesn't make
you happy other notable gaming
billionaires include minecraft director
Markus notch Pearson and valve head Gabe
Newell despite kiss Lee's modest
lifestyle we can all look forward to the
near future when he outfits jay-z and
Beyonce in a Beverly Hills mansion and
parties with Selena Gomez next up is a
story for gamers with an average amount
of money who we call normies in Normie
news Pokemon Sun and Moon was listed
today trademark applications for Pokemon
Sun and Moon including logos have been
published on a European trademark
registry discovered by nerd leaks the
listing state they were filed today the
Nintendo Direct briefing which was
expecting big news
takes place tomorrow this might have
been leaked note that the trademark
registrations don't always mount to
product releases additionally there's no
mention in the listings that Pokemon Sun
and Moon or games and to add to that
Pokemon Sun and Moon appear to be the
names of fan-made games you can see it
right here the Pokemon themed Nintendo
Direct kicks off tomorrow februari 26 at
7am gamespot will have all the news as
it's announced so hopefully this one's
real finally there are some things you
just can't put a number on truly
exquisite pieces that are priceless
things like Resident Evil's for resident
evil 5 and resident evil 6 coming to
Xbox one and ps4 you can't put a number
on things like that they're going to be
listed for twenty dollars apiece all
rich people enjoy a good full-body port
and today capcom announced today that
all three games are coming to new
consoles beginning with resident evil 6
in march each game is gonna be 20 bucks
Resident Evil 6 is re-release will come
with all previously released add-on
content including costumes and more
resident evil Phibes release is slated
for summer 2016 with resident evil 4
coming this fall Capcom also announced
that physical disc versions will be
available in the Americas though no
further details were provided publisher
didn't say if the new versions of any
games will be upgraded with better
graphics or if they'll just be a
standard torch in many ways gamespot
news is like this six-year-old Kentucky
rye whiskey it's rich full-bodied and
I'm about to finish it right now see you
guys again tomorrow
you